losing weight is harder I go live this
is the memoirs of a baby fat man cold
why the hell does everything bad you got
to taste so damn good
that's some [ __ ] I love the Donna
beat the hammer glad you're sorry yes
for making your food taste so good and
be so damn cheap oh you'll make a double
cheeseburger and chicken a dollar hmm
plus any side street for dollar that's
$3 a whole meal and I suppose say no to
that huh
and I'm crazy look let me out for a
second I'm weak and I'm also broke I'm
broke I don't know what you think oh
well guess what he has a Macbook a
bubble but you ain't never heard of a
credit card dumbass
not a single damn thing about how oh I'm
weak and I'm broke that's right ladies
sorry you think that I have money just
grab a comedian Oh in America that [ __ ]
automatically equals fence this [ __ ] is
a handicap boxing match I'm fine against
myself will and my economic status
well David there are other options
Subway's cheap [ __ ]
so I don't taste like a cheeseburger now
do it eh well then if you want to be bad
enough you would lose the weight
shut yo skinny Olsen twit answer [ __ ]
you think I'm gonna have breasts you
think I like doing jumping jacks in
having my please [ __ ] my mouth think
I like walking around have my inner
thighs rub each other all the time you
don't know what that's like do you you
think I like being mistaken for Rosie
O'Donnell's I two milkshakes away for
making spandex and every big part about
wardrobe Thanks laughs let me tell you
something anybody out there that says
they love big fat you were in on it I
believe that you can accept it if you
don't want to change it and move on with
life but nobody's happy being morbidly
obese I have yet to be a man or woman
probably standing for I love taking
buffets out of business almost overly
obese people don't like being fed they
just deal with it better than a lot of
other people I happen to be a fat man
without too many self-esteem issues
about my weight but I recently want to
lose some weight monk let me tell you
something weight loss is a [ __ ] up
strength every day I wake up I'm Sora
I'm Sora
I don't know how but I swear to you this
morning my teeth were sore my teeth hurt
have you ever worked out so much that
your hair follicles her
it's not a haircut my hair just fell out
I heard some of the dumbest [ __ ] I bet
someone said that they love being sore
because it's a sign of a good workout
man shut the hell up it jump off a
bridge you want to be so many nine five
go ahead go commit a crime end up in
prison there'll be some muscular man
that I make you feel sore every night
you know food a lot of us bigger people
food is an addiction I know it's hard to
understand but it's an addiction we love
it like North Koreans love Kim Jong Il
Oh too soon is that too soon to make
that joke for a lot of us large people
food is an addiction it's not something
we like it no [ __ ] we love it we lie
well maybe you should stop [ __ ] dig the
food cuz I quit smoking how long you
been smoking for what seven eight years
[ __ ] advocating for my whole life and
what the hell is this [ __ ] if I'm
looking at how many calories I can eat
per day if I want to lose two pounds per
week and it says 1600 calories [ __ ]
I've eaten the 1600 calorie burrito ones
the hell about fulfill my stomach for
the rest day hopes and dreams for those
of you who are trying to lose weight
be strong be resilient trust me I got
your back like a tiger in the woods
we're golfing champion we I'm hungry I'm
just thinking
look at where I came from
Mama's any of you have watched the movie
101 Dalmatians Cruella Deville exists
right there what happened all the
puppies what'd you do with all the
puppies give me back my puppies